all aboard for safety an adventure
narrator doesn't pause with a very
obvious ellipsis why it's actually
flame-retardant
I believe the modern term is explosively
disabled sterling it's totally sick well
except for the bomb threat you not
Captain Stubing you took my sin it was
suppose we could bump mrs. Beakman well
me I'm not go if these two can share a
cabin but you just said actually we are
fully booked so how would Lana and
Archer sharing a cabin even be possible
if there are zero cabins available
Mallory come on let me stay with you and
we'll do the whole Oprah Gale thing even
in 2010 I'm pretty sure the Oprah Gale
thing was past its pop culturally
relevant expiration date am i taking a
cent off for one of the funniest running
gags ever on a TV show I think I will
because I like living in the danger zone
I went through these sexy silhouettes
one by one because I have a job to do
here they all look good except what's up
with this one what is protruding from
her waist she injured did she try and
use a tiny hoop did she come down with a
sudden case of yzma boobs
there's almost full car length between
the cars parked in this row
that's just inefficient use of your lot
space if you ask me the director said
let's have our true eating a pear that's
close enough to an Apple to make him
look like even more of an [ __ ]
vessel of any kind with passengers on
board doesn't make an announcement that
they are about to take off zero please
be discreet hey good advice which maybe
I'll just sort of fold in with my 12
years of experience as a covert
operative for those 12 years teach you
to display your guns by your guns at all
time well being discreet because I don't
think it did what the hell is going on
with North America on this map Florida
appears to be flaccid lease idling up to
Mexico like some sort of limp penis
insulin and then Michigan is just a
northern blob of land completely ruining
the ability of locals to geolocate by
pointing at their hand on second thought
I like this map let's keep it either
I tell Lana what happened on that
scratchy green office rug or two you get
inside me did you ever have a teacher
who wanted you to pass so bad they give
you multiple choice questions with
answer so obvious you couldn't pick
wrong if you try yeah just curious and
are you just gonna sit there yeah until
she tags me in I'm kidding my back's all
messed up ah you somehow climb to the
top of this console with a bad back and
your Pam I'm guessing a bad back has
never prevented you from tagging in
before my vulva is smoother than a Wilk
remember just a cartoon
remember Lana's just a cartoon mr.singh
win can't have a showdown with only one
hanging plus Bacharach means zero not a
20-9 show doesn't know how to baccarat
correctly but then again neither do I
really so that makes two cents right
holy did I just see Cheryl's veal cutlet
that's what love is Lana it's forgive e
if that's true in my sixteenth favorite
foreigner song is only the sudden very
anticlimactic Oh half naked it's
bouncing around like you're at a rodeo I
am clearly attending the wrong rodeos
and yet you lecture me there is no way
that Lana had time to even hit the speed
down number and the time it took her to
grab the phone from her maybe she had it
in guess it could have been ah ha
finally Archer makes the mistake of
showing us the timer here at 11:11 but
17 seconds later when they show it again
it reads 1054 wait that adds up fine but
exactly one minute 51 seconds later when
they show it again it says 903 ok yeah
still right but a minute and 39 seconds
later it's still exactly correct and 37
seconds later when they cut the cord and
it speeds up it's still accurate to the
exact second what the hell are Chur it
wasn't enough with this final defusing
of the bombs one of the funniest most
clever and well written comedy pieces in
the history of television
you also have to have a precisely
accurate bomb countdown this [ __ ]
show is trying to put us out of a job
and I may be the biggest sin of them all
but also based on the sound of the
countdown beeps you can do when the
counter speeds up that the counter is
counting down exactly four times as fast
and when we see the timer 78 seconds
later exactly 312 seconds have clicked
off the clock
meaning even when they had a reasonable
excuse for not giving a flying airships
about the timer accuracy they still got
it exactly correct sometimes you just
have to know when you're beat you win
Archer you win
well then who did it I did how did Lana
and Archer not see this guy until now
also why would captain Lammers even
bother calling Isis to investigate the
bomb threat if he was going to actually
put a bomb on board yes he didn't make
the bomb threat but he didn't have to
call someone to investigate
captain Lammers nice read Velma oh my
god this shows us the best apparently
everybody you were fully booked
remember see so captain Lammers isn't
going to shoot Lana and Archer before
jumping off the blimp
they could still disarm the bomb and
ruin his plan now there should be a dash
followed by two letters okay so now I
want you to cut this little exchange
will lead to a hilarious
misunderstanding since ray thinks the
two letters are oh and Kate but Archer
clearly wasn't looking at the serial
number when he said that and he's
clearly not been following the NATO
phonetic alphabet and Ray just accepts
this okay is the letter C needs without
a second thought
so wait which one do I cut but he's
watching them on video so they should be
able to show ray the wires and he can
identify which one to cut Lana you can
be pissed off all you want but you were
there when Archer said Nancy and you
didn't say a goddamn word starting with
the fact we just bombed Ireland pretty
sure that's Wales geography snobs
make sure you click that bell icon
but clicking the little bell icon is how
you make sure you get notified every
time we release a video so click join
never hang around the gymnasium some
broad gets on there with a staticky
sweater and bow Oh captain my captain
sit down mr. Anderson we are on a break
we were on a break well you know hi God
see sky so I had a wife but beautiful
like you
captain Lammers nice read Velma and I
would have gotten away with it if it
weren't for you meddling kids
it's Niner three four tango x-ray Sierra
why did I catch a Niner in there where
you're calling from all walkie talkie